prélever 2 les corses de platanes pour
mesurer la pollution de l'air c'était
l'objectif de l'association ensemble
vivons versailles armés de leurs sacs de
congélation
un petit groupe de membres a donc
récupéré sur une quarantaine d'arbres 2
les corses
cette opération s'inscrit dans un projet
citoyen nommé et corsair ce projet et
corsair ne l'a pas inventé c'est la
sorbonne universités qui a tout nié tout
un ensemble de programmes pour permettre
aux citoyens seulement d'être acteurs de
la prise de données scientifiques et
donc on les envoie à un institut à
laboratoires de recherche qui fait les
mesures et après on va avoir dans le
mois qui vient les résultats et le but
c'est qu'on reproduise à plusieurs
encore une fois plusieurs dans plusieurs
artères et plusieurs moments cette
opération a été organisée sur la célèbre
avenue de paris où se situe le lycée la
bruyère de versailles et l'association a
bien choisi son jour le 29 mars début
des débats dans l'hémicycle du projet de
loi climat et résilience à ce titre le
député didier baichère a participé aux
prélèvements je pense qu'en en
impliquant les citoyens dans ces mesures
de pollution on se rendra mieux compte
collectivement qu'effectivement la
transition écologique c'est possible à
tron à notre niveau et c'est absolument
essentiel pour le futur
ce projet de loi il a il a vraiment une
ambition importante il va il va apporter
un certain nombre d'indicateurs d'éco
responsabilité pour que justement là
aussi on puisse avoir des indicateurs de
mesure précise si le prélèvement cible
le platane c'est parce qu il régénère
ces écorces chaque année permettant de
ne faire aucun préjudice alarme
l'association a donc prévu de renouveler
l'opération chaque année pour 2021
résultat d'ici un mois environ pour
connaître le taux de pollution dans
l'air sur la venue de paris à versailles